oui
[Musique]
on
à la découverte des marais de bourges le
poumon vert de la ville
un petit coin de paradis à quelques
minutes du centre ville historique et de
la cathédrale saint-etienne 135 hectares
de terres des centaines de parcelles
cultivées par les maraîchers depuis plus
d'un siècle
depuis que les jésuites ont transformé
ces marécages en jardin potager
parfaitement irriguer un écrin de
verdure classé au patrimoine naturel
une nature préservée un îlot riches en
biodiversité et des jardins
amoureusement entretenu
c'est une il ya qu un seul moyen pour
venir de tels bateaux à la nage
j'en habite en ville dans un appartement
comme beaucoup de maraîchers
il a décidé d'acheter ce marais à la
retraite alors qu'ils ne s'y connaissait
pas vraiment en jardinage
c'était surtout pour m'occuper ça
pourquoi j'ai cherché une occupation
après une activité de jeux travailler 50
ans à peu près et dont une activité
assez intense qu'est ce que je sais dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique dans le
commercial depuis le potager a bien
prospéré
il cultive oignons radis carottes
salades sans oublier de belles roses
rouges une occupation qui prend du temps
je viens trois après-midis part seul en
général là lille mercredi le vendredi
jamais le week-end on dit que les
retraités sont débordés mais widgets
cité basse
un cadre idyllique un îlot de
tranquillité accessible seulement en
barque par endroits des jardins privés à
l'abri des regards indiscrets
denis julien s'est installé aux
fourneaux du restaurant la course il
hier il y a trente ans la réputation de
sa tarte tatin à vite effacer les
frontières du berry il ne se lasse
toujours pas d'admirer les paysages
changeants des marais tous les matins le
paysage à différents parce que il ya les
poux qui a de la faune encore le plus
beau des marais fait au printemps avant
les folles parce que la terre et noir
les premiers bourgeons les premières
pousses
la perspective sur les cabanes un peu
folklo ces magnifiques les marins au
siècle dernier la course il hier était
une guinguette dans l'entre-deux-guerres
on venait boire et danser danser bal
populaire très animé
c'était un bal considéré comme une
guinguette qui se tenait bien n'y avait
pas de bagarre comme
dans certaines autres guinguette
où il y avait toujours des bagarres ici
c'était bien tenu et c'était un monsieur
qui avait une pâte en bois comme il dit
et comme ils disaient les vieux
jardinier quand on est arrivés pas de
lui parce que il avait eu à la guerre à
une jambe de coupe et donc qui servait
de ça pour le comme autorité pour taper
le fun après les clients voilà pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale c'était même
un bal clandestins aujourd'hui la cour
civière est l'un des deux restaurants
encore établie au coeur des marais
[Musique]
alain aime voyager dans son marais à 74
ans il a toujours l'habitude de pêcher à
la main ancien ouvrier le michelin il
vient ici tous les matins et presque
tous les après midi
aujourd'hui il a décidé de faire de
nouvelles semences
moi j'ai répondu maraige pas plus que ça
fait 17 ans que je suis en retraite et
marais massé tout un
on a des copains fait des petits casques
outre les années qui viennent nous voir
tout ça c'est bien
ses amis le surnomment le chef de
culture
mais par dessus tout alain aime
l'ambiance conviviale démarré ici tout
le monde se connaît et s'entraide si
besoin à deux pas du bar improvisé s'est
habitué jouissent d'une vue imprenable
sur la cathédrale
il a passé 60 ans dans les marais
marcellin ferrand vient de fêter ses 94
ans dans son livre il raconte ses
souvenirs de facteurs marc iché faisait
la tournée toute la journée et après moi
tourné le soir
à l'époque les pelles du barrage du
lierre deviennent automatiques les eaux
du parking carrefour se déverser
directement dans les fossés inquiet pour
l'avenir des marais le facteur décide de
créer en 1970 une association de défense
baptisé depuis patrimoine marais on
prenait presque pour réduire le merlu
alors il a fallu quand même essayer de
sensibiliser les maraîchers sur ce qui
les attendait s'il n'y avait rien de
fait moi je leur ai dit vous savez si on
n'essaie pas de trade association pour
améliorer la situation dans dix ans on
pourra parler au marais et l'ancien
facteur avait vu juste
aujourd'hui encore ce jardin d'éden est
menacée nous embarquons avec le
président de l'association des
maraîchers depuis les années 2000 la
jussie a envahi les cours d'eau cette
algue importée du brésil est vendu dans
les jardineries menace la flore
aquatique et bouchent les faux si elle
est vraiment rageant car on est obligé
de faire des arrachages tous les ans
puis d'encourager les maraîchers ça
passe là c'est complètement déplacé
boucher parce qu'elle va très vite
ouaddou en l'espace de quinze jours et
surtout pas l'a fauché parce que quand
même quand vous l'arracher faut mettre
des barrages pour empêcher qu'il ya un
petit morceau biscaye au fil de l'eau
parce qu'il serait un stalag heures il
refait un pied un peu plus loin dans les
marais duo de langis déversent des
déchets retenu par ce barrage flottant
un petit aménagement obtenu de haute
lutte par l'association on va trouver
une petite télévision à une cuve de
machines à laver enfin entre autres
entre autres déchets divers on va dire
absolument
c'est ce qu'on ne voit pas et que des
analyses de 2010 sont révélèrent savoir
l'arrivée ici il y avait des
prélèvements is it ont été faits
l'onema office national de l'eau et donc
ils ont trouvé des excès du plomb et de
nickel dans cette partie là ce qui veut
pas dire qu'elle n'a partout dans les
marais mais à l'arrivée en tout cas
c'est ce qu'ils ont trouvé dans les
bases pour protéger cet écosystème
france camuzat demande des bassins de
décantation et des analyses de l'eau
plus régulière des vases et c'est bien
c'est du curatif mais le préventif il
faudra essayer de trouver une solution
savoir que ça déjà ça que ça se soit
récupéré alors c'est bien le récupérer
là mais tout ce qui est invisible
on ne récupère pas là pour des qui
puisse y avoir des dix thèmes de
décantation en amont de cette de ce
cours d'eau qui puisse récupérer tous et
henri du port à 100% mais au moins la
majorité des déchets chimiques et autres
que puisse est récupérée pour l'instant
c'est pas le cas
un autre péril menace ce sont les marées
à l'abandon certains jardins sont en
friche depuis plus de 50 ans des ronces
et des arbres poussent de manière
sauvage comme ce marais délaissé depuis
très longtemps
il a fallu de longues recherches pour
retrouver l'ancien propriétaire morte en
56 aucun héritier ne s'est manifesté ça
peut pas rester comme ça toute manière
dans la mesure où par exemple vous voyez
les fossés autour il se comble et se
bouche
donc ça c'est pas c'est pas acceptable
donc effectivement il peut y avoir des
perspectives à réfléchir de cette horde
mais que ce soit maîtrisée quand même
qui a une
un certain caractère d'entretien con
qu'on laisse peut-être des arbres dedans
mais qu'on comptera ce pas qu'on laisse
pas sa danse était à quoi ça me paraît
difficile
marc est allouée à vendre et surtout
plus du tout entretenu avec l'aide de
l'association la mairie a procédé à un
recensement des parcelles sur 1400
propriétaire 150 sont inconnues ou
introuvables juridiquement c'est ce
qu'on appelle des biens sans maître ces
friches elle pose plusieurs problèmes
un problème bad pour la vie des marais
un problème tout bêtement esthétique
mais aussi des problèmes parfois de
sécurité ou des problèmes de sécurité
des personnes ou des biens et puis
simplement sa race ce n'est peut-être
permet plus aux marais de vivre comme on
aimerait qu'ils vivent et donc il faut
qu'on sache quelle est l'étendue des
dégâts et pourquoi on a ces friches et
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour y
répondre
la mairie a financé des campagnes de
curage découlant mais elle n'a pas
encore lancé de procédure contre les
propriétaires négligents en attendant
une nouvelle génération cultive les
marais autrement
nathalie et christophe se sont installés
ici il y a trois ans avec une idée
s'inspirer de la permaculture pour
produire leurs légumes c'est du plaisir
parce qu'en fait ce que j'aime dans la
permaculture c'est qu'on pense avant et
pour non agir ensuite
donc c'est ça que j'aime beaucoup j'ai
eu une expérience dans un maraîchage en
bio mais qui était une échelle plus
grande est beaucoup plus productive et
et je me suis pas senti à mon aise et
surtout qu'ils ont j'applique est pas le
prince et le paillage par exemple et
donc oui le jeu favorise oui le nom nagy
christophe se sert d'un drôle d'outil la
grelinette pour laisser les vers de
terre et autres micro-organismes
travailler la terre à sa place
horticulteur de métier il s'est
récemment converti à la permaculture
et le résultat est bien là juste à
laisser pousser pas d'arrosage pas de
désherbage pas d'entretien alors rien
j'ai l'amour de l'amour et quelques
principes tout de même ils mélangent
savamment légumes fleurs et fruits sur
un lit de paille
donc là je me dis quand je muscade
provence au pied des bases et pieds de
vigne en fait là je vais venir faire
joli bas mettent une capucine qui va
aussi avoir fait bien fait 2-2 puis
seront j'espère les
un automate et si la nature travaille
bien il y aura des fruits et légumes en
quantité à la belle saison
mais d'autres petits habitants peuplent
aussi les marais canards poules d'eau et
autres foulques ont pris l'habitude de
niche et de se reproduire dans cette
zone préservée et trouve ici toute la
nourriture nécessaire
sébastien bonnier de l'association
nature 18 est attentif à l'évolution de
la faune et de la flore dans ces zones
humides en régression un peu partout sur
la planète
en 2019 les produits phytosanitaires
seront interdits dans les jardins des
particuliers parle souvent des abeilles
un mais des pollinisateurs
effectivement les produits chimiques ont
un impact directement sur les
pollinisateurs et - ya de pollinisateurs
polliniser et moi c'est intéressant même
pour l'activité humaine grenouille et
libellules en profite très gourmande en
insecte elles s'épanouissent
tranquillement dans les fossés des
marais eux aussi ont trouvé leur petit
coin de paradis
selon ge et christian ont réalisé leur
rêve vivre dans les marais bienvenue
dans la basse-cour volaille canards oies
et même des lapins vives qui s'y
pressent quant aux talibés rté lacs
selon j'aime jouer à la fermière
même si ces poules ils font des tours
elle retrouve des dizaines de cacher un
peu partout sur la parcelle et les
distribuer gratuitement quoi vous faites
ça alors on va se semblait c'est pas une
vendeuse dans une donneuse
voilà je ne sais pas vendre je sais que
donner
son mari lui donne des salades retraité
des chemins de fer il cultive un
deuxième arrêt juste en face au fil du
temps c'est un peu devenu leur résidence
secondaire l'été en couches ici voyez
pendant deux mois au moins on est bien
on est bien c'est la crcc mais c'est pas
explicable même quand on a dans le sens
qu'on est bien ici on l'a dans le sang
et sa bouche pulpeuse
on vient tous les jours on peut on part
en vacances jamais jamais mais on vient
ici tous les jours même l'hiver un
apprenti à de la glace et on vient ici
on costa glace et on vient
à deux pas du centre ville de bourges
cet endroit jadis confidentiel est
devenu le rendez vous des amoureux de la
nature